i don't uh i don't walk around with cash  usually oh i do  do you oh yeah let's see how much cash i  have on me this could be fun i got some  do the whole thing oh you know what i do  have cash on me on the table please yeah  i got cash  how much do you have on you should we  count yep wow you got a lot now what the  hell  yeah count it  oh man  see i got a lot of fives and and tens  because of tips and stuff yeah yeah yeah  but let's see  yeah i got about like 150 or so here i  don't have a ton of cash on me oh man  look at that  mark what are you no this is not smart  to me you know you don't have to mark  what the hell man what the hell are you  doing oh my god why did you eat this  kind of nut store i mean this is over a  thousand dollars in cash  leave that for the intern man